my wife I'll force is true I'm just
gonna keep it simple I don't blame her
just hours after et confirmed Jersey
Shore star Jenni JWoww Farley had filed
for divorce her husband of less than
three years Rodger Matthews turned to
Instagram to confirm the news here's
what's also true I'm not done fighting
I'm gonna win my wife back our affection
back I'm gonna win her love back I have
no intentions of being a single dad
we're in counseling so there is hope and
you know what the fat lady sings
the 43 year old truck driver captioned
the post quilt praying for a better
tomorrow there's no cheating I think
done in a juicy details it's just grew
tired of the repetitive pattern that we
fell into the couple share two children
together four-year-old daughter Milani
and two-year-old son Grayson and in 2016
ét sat down with a reality star where
she got candid about her marriage he's
my best friend he's the only person in
this world that puts me in my place so I
actually respect him even more for that
and I love him for that because he can
call me out on my BS we've been together
almost seven years you know day in day
out especially raising two children I
almost feel like it's easier to quit and
a lot of relationships do so we are just
always constantly trying to find that
happy medium and it takes work Snooki
told us for her and Jionni divorce is
not an option do you feel like you and
Roger live by that same mentality
no no cuz there are third deal-breakers
in our relationship that we would
separate over I think yeah I like the
cheating
you know Affairs things like that things
that you can't go back like you can't go
back in time and fix but yeah I would
never say it's not an option because if
you're truly unhappy you shouldn't stay
in a relationship
[Music]
[Applause]